yesterday at their historic summit
President Trump played a video that he
prepared for Kim jong-un this is not a
joke this is absolutely real the video
was done in the style of a fake
Hollywood movie trailer Trump and I
guess and his team prepared it for Kim
jong-un and they showed it to him this
is some of the real actual video Trump
showed Kim jong-un will this leader
choose to advance his country and be
part of a new world be the hero of his
people will he shake the hand of peace
and enjoy prosperity like he has never
seen a great life or more isolation that
is a real video Trump played for Kim
jong-un during the meeting what people
don't know is that Kim jong-un prepared
a video of his own for president Trump
and guess what we're the only show to
get our hands on this video that's right
this is the video Kim jong-un played for
Donald Trump during their meeting at a
time when the planet is spinning out of
control two men have an opportunity to
forge a path towards galactic prosperity
peacefulness and peace our Golden Dawn
the smells of endless flowers and fresh
rose coffee in the smiles of babies a
world filled with technology like big
levers and buttons and robots who will
never enslave us there are two paths
before you dawn the small path of
stinkiness was a great role of general
city this is your chance to be
remembered among the great leaders in
the history of humanity a land of
prosperity and goodness where all of
your enemies get their just deserts
where all of your dreams come true
a world where Donald Trump is
immortalized in North Korea and Kim
jong-un is embraced as America's
greatest son and now we are very pleased
and honored to present to the United
States of America
montage of fireworks
[Music]
[Music]
please send check for six hundred
billion dollars to kim jongmin peel box
yes five thousand
[Applause]
you